we'd look around and say hey how come
everybody's not saying this is amazing i
mean we're going to dethrone ibm
if you're going to try something
innovative then then you're in
unexplored territories so that
odds that something will go wrong are
pretty high we needed a different group
of managers
and virtually the entire management team
had to be replaced
and that means i had to ask people who
i'd worked with for a decade
to leave want to be happy build a life
not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and get some success advice
from the top
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one trust your ideas with bill
gates
the key thing was that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was
uh 13 and 8th grade when this time
sharing terminal came in and we just
did it day and night and you know got
better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law
exponential improvement that that was a
magic combination and we we'd look
around and say hey how come everybody's
not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
going to dethrone ibm
and uh you know why doesn't digital
equipment get it why is the guy who runs
it
this is a company that's long gone uh
but dominated many computers at the time
why isn't that guy up there saying it's
it's wrong we know it's right
and so the key event for us was it was a
very cold
boston winter and a kid computer came
out on uh this popular electronics
magazine
and we said oh damn this is happening
without us
i mean here we are uh doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready
uh and then we called them back we
actually did the work and then we called
them back and said
how do you make the stuff go in and out
of the computer
the i o and they said well that's
interesting nobody else has ever asked
that you must really be doing something
so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it
to be the very first and we were the
first to say there should be a software
industry
and come and do it in a sense it was one
of the lower risk things i've ever done
in my life because
you know i could have always gone back
uh you know what
my parents my dad didn't say hey if you
go away for a few years i'll stop paying
for education they were nice and said
okay go
you know learn your lesson down there in
the desert and uh
then you get back to the serious stuff
and you know we're still
we're still waiting lesson number two
lean into the future with jeff bezos
as number one on the list we're talking
to steve case yesterday
and he had been number one and a couple
of years later he was not on the list
well you're making me really nervous no
no don't be nervous just tell me
what could happen that would do that to
you and amazon
and how do you prevent that do you worry
it could all come unraveled
well i kind of have this experience kind
of already happened to me because
you put me on the cover of time
magazine's person of the year in 1999
and about a year later the internet
bubble burst i think
amazon's stock went from 113 dollars a
share to six or something like that
so these things happen the thing for
companies is you need to be um
nimble and robust so you need to be able
to take a punch
uh and you also need to be quick and and
and innovative and
and doing new things at a high speed
that's that's the best defense against
the future
and you have to always be leaning into
the future if you're
if you're leaning away from the future
the future is going to win
every time never ever ever lean away
from the future
lesson number three accept failures with
elon musk
if you're gonna try something innovative
then then you're in unexplored
territories
so that odds that something will go
wrong are pretty high
uh if you know it's only if you try to
do something that is already well
understood that
um there's a little little chance of
failure um
but then it will not be interesting or
innovative
so you know for sure uncharted territory
will result
in failures
necessarily otherwise you know trying
hard enough lesson number four
control your thoughts with grant cardone
i know that one of the key
things one of the things that's made me
successful in my life
is making it a priority to control
my thoughts like what what am i thinking
about like literally
putting discipline in on how i talk to
myself
and so i don't want this to sound all
the cycle babble stuff it's not like
it's not like oh if you just stand in
the mirror and talk to yourself and say
positive things everything's gonna be
all right that's not true
be careful what you say to yourself okay
because if you're saying a thirty dollar
stake is a lot of money
or a four dollar toy is a lot of money
when your kid wants a four dollar toy
listen to what you're saying
that's a lot of money dude four dollars
is a lot of money
okay on my worst day four dollars has
not been a lot of money even though
okay i've been at periods in my life
where i didn't have four dollars
so i'm talking to you today about
how do you control how do you control
how do you discipline how do you start
monitoring
what you're saying to yourself i can't
find the right girl
can't find the right guy there's no good
guys left in this town
all men are pigs women cheat on their
men
marriage is hard having kids is
difficult
i don't want to pay taxes
you know i can't help myself i can't
stop
i can't trust myself i never do what i
say i procrastinate
i'm an introvert
i'm broke i'm poor so look what are you
saying to yourself
all the time the first thing i did was i
took a i took a little journal out and i
just wrote down all the negative things
i say to myself by the way i just gave
you the list
okay i can't spend money
i can't save enough money i don't make
enough money
okay i don't know how to invest in the
stock market i can't invest in real
estate
i don't have time to do this you know
the time thing people just kill
themselves with the time thing i don't
have enough time i don't have enough
time i don't have enough time
guess what oops you don't have enough
time
you don't have time you don't have money
catch yourself every time you say
i don't have time say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money i
create money
um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire i own
if you want to if you're in the
apartment game and you want to be in
apartments but you don't know anything
about apartments you can start literally
talking to yourself saying i am worth
uh uh or i own 100 units i did this for
years for years before i ever bought an
apartment i used to write down i own 20
apartments
that earns 12 cash flow all right
over and over i bet i bet i wrote this
down a thousand times
i own 20 apartments my first deal was 38
units
i own 20 apartments or more and and i
write it in any little journal
any piece of paper any legal path every
time you say something negative write
down
uh i need to lose weight okay
that's good but you know if you're
running a race
you don't say i need to finish the race
you're like you're looking for that
you're you gotta run
right you got to run you got to move you
got to keep moving your feet so i mean
you can sit there and say i got to
finish this race but the truth is
if you need to lose weight man just once
you pick your target weight
and start affirming that i weigh 165
pounds
i weigh 165 pounds so just switch it a
little bit right
all you're trying to do is discipline
you're trying to move the river
so if you're broke right now quit saying
i am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five be able to make
hard decisions with larry ellison there
are lots of times especially in the
early days uh that were that were very
very difficult
i think i think the most difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its had its only lost quarter in
history and we've been in business for
20 years of the 20 years we lost money
one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almost we doubled our
sales virtually every year for
for ten years nine out of ten years ten
out of eleven years it was really quite
an amazing run we're the
fastest growing company in history still
we still are the fastest growing company
in history
over a long period of time and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we reached a
billion dollars in revenue
and we were having serious management
problems all over the place and
the people who were running the company
the billion dollar company were the same
people that
run the company when we were a 50
million dollar company one 20th the size
and i hadn't had an incredible sense of
loyalty
to those people who'd worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that people who are
good at running a 50 million dollar
company are not necessarily those aren't
the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse the just entirely
different skill set
in running a 50 million company than a
billion dollar company
and uh both skill sets are rare and
precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually
the entire management team had to be
replaced and that means i had to ask
people
who i'd worked with for a decade to
leave i had to fire people
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business
asking that you know a bunch of people
to
leave oracle i had no choice and if they
even asked them to leave oracle or
everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was thousands of people worked at
oracle
uh they deserved the best leadership we
could find
uh and
my primary my primary responsibility
was to the company and all of the staff
you know all of our shareholders and all
of our customers
and uh therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go lesson number six
break your limitations with jesse itzler
why the point of having a seal live with
you this is this book's called living
with the seal 31 days
training with the toughest man on the
planet and i watched a few videos on
this guy as a freak
but why did you decide to to have him
live with you
when he first moved in the first he
comes into the house and he has
a little knapsack for 30 days if i go
away for 30 days i'm checking two bags
he has this little like huck fin for 30
days with all his clothes and everything
and
his whole life in the bag and i said to
him his name is david goggins so if
you're listening and
you know him or you want to google him i
said in the book i referred to him as
seal
but now you know he's out there so he
came to the house and i said to him you
know hey
here's your room you know i'll show you
around make yourself at home and you
know my home is your home for the next
30 days and you said no no
he said i don't have a home and i said
no make yourself at home it's an
expression
and he said i don't operate in
expressions wow
and that was sort of like okay let's
start
so that was that was kind of our opening
act no settling in no
yeah and then we went down to the uh gym
five minutes into the into our 31 day
journey
and um he said i want to see how many
pull-ups you can do
so i said all right so uh i guess to
kind of get a level of like where i was
at and i am not a strong
guy so i did maybe eight pull-ups and
then i dropped down
and it's all right wait 30 seconds and
do it again do it again so i waited 30
seconds got back up on the bar
i did like six he said all right one
more time and now like i'm starting to
feel it you know like i
i don't think i can even get back up on
the bar and i get i get
three but three like you know kicking
getting my chin over like whatever i
could do to get over the bar
so i said all right what's next he said
what's next is we're gonna stay here
until you do a hundred more
oh my gosh and i said you're doing one
at a time and i'm like come on man
like that's great on paper but i
physically can't
do 100 more and um
that was our start of many lessons that
i learned because i ended up
doing it one at a time and what he
taught me was that so many
of our limitations are self-imposed
you know and we set we set something up
in our brain we program our brain one
way
and that's our limit and until we can
get past that and
see what we're really made of and like
get uncomfortable and experience
pain you can't real you don't really
don't know what you're capable of
yeah so that was a really good good
lesson for me
and um every day was a lesson like that
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip is put
in the sweat equity with mark cuban
raising money
always seems to be like the big thing to
entrepreneurs coming in well if i can
only raise this money
raising money isn't an accomplishment
it's an obligation
the best equity is sweat equity you know
what you can do and what you seriously
if you're putting in the
if you're putting in the sweat and
you're putting in the time and you're
not out there
raising money and you're grinding it out
and you're hustling then you deserve to
give yourselves a hand because that's
what it's all about
because if you don't do that it's not
going to work
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35
to 91 chance of you actually following
through and
when you share your plan publicly that
jumps to
95 chance of following through so i want
that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below
so i can celebrate you speaking of
learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes
what was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him
and what was the show and what'd you
learn yeah the show was called the rebel
billionaire and it was the apprentice
version richard branson's version of
that they were looking for 16
entrepreneurs so i'm like hey i'm an
entrepreneur i want to do this and i
really wanted to meet richard
i sort of had set intentions out there
that i was gonna
manifest him becoming a friend in my
life so when i heard about the show i
was like oh this is interesting this
might be how this happens
so i applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how how big was
spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of
it was pretty i mean it was four years
in it was doing great
yeah multiple seven figures and stuff
yeah my lawyers begged me not to do it
they're like what are you doing
you own this company you're gonna do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance
so um so yeah and and all the business
challenges took place around the world
in different cities
and instead of if you didn't win the
business challenge going into a board
room to get fired you had to do
a crazy stunt like a world record
breaking stunt because richard is
obviously like a huge adrenaline junkie
guy
so um in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9000 feet in the air on a
dangling rope ladder and have tea climb
to the top and have tea
on top of the balloon with richard it's
insane it's insane
what did you guys talk about on the top
oh my god i talked about like how do we
get down and that's what he said you
climb back down i was like
what i didn't think about that it was so
scary yeah oh my gosh
yeah so it took me 48 minutes to climb
to the top
it's at the height of a 17-story
building and the dangling rope ladder
was just like hanging out into the abyss
of nothingness
wasn't anchored to anything so i'm like
climbing it
and um there's cameras that was the
first day of filming
so two months later i know i like
cameras up there
yes helicopters circling
probably i had to do all these crazy
stunts the next stop i had to do is i
had to jump off the side of the victoria
falls gorge in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and my
guy on my team was dangling on a wire
on a crane 10 feet out from the cliff
and each person had to come up and stand
there and you couldn't run and jump and
you had to stand still and jump
and if he caught you you were okay and
they'd put you back on the cliff
and if not you fell 385 feet on a bungee
cord
and so i am beyond terrified of heights
it's like one of my
i'm so afraid of heights i cry on
airplanes still during takeoff a lot of
times
and i was one of the only people to make
the jump richard didn't make the jump
all these other guys that were like
amazing athletes didn't make the jump
and i like to talk about this because i
always talk about aiming high
and the importance of aiming high in
life and then i think all of us we don't
aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's
saying you know if you shoot for the
moon if you miss you're at least with
the stars
and afterwards everyone was like sarah
how did you make that jump you're
literally
like the only contestant look at you i
said well i was aimed at the pulley
six feet above his head where were you
aiming
and i aimed i didn't even look at him i
aimed six feet above
his head and i landed at his waist and
he caught me and everybody else was
aiming at his face
and landed at his feet and missed
amazing so it's like a really just
poignant
example of the importance of aiming high
in all areas of life yeah
if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you have to be super clear
about what kind of company you're trying
to build what's your approach is
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life
is and what our chosen profession is
going to be at 22